here is White House Press Secretary
cringe Jean-Pierre and she's not having
it either when it comes to this whole
story
wouldn't answer James's question though
are you going to answer the question
without not a reasonable question to ask
for the president United States Who's
involved as this message seems to
suggest in some sort of uh coercive
conversation for business dealing by a
son is that something if he wasn't then
maybe you should tell us so here's the
thing and I appreciate the question I
believe my colleague at the White House
Council has answered this question
already has dealt with this has uh made
it very clear I just don't have anything
to share outside of what my colleagues
have shared and so I would refer you to
him and the and the doj just not going
to comment from here
I will what I can tell you is I know
that my colleague has dealt with this he
addressed this at the White House
Council I just don't have anything else
to share I just I just answered the
question I just answered the questions
yes or no was the president involved
Stephen Stephen I just answered the
question I just said I just this is it's
not up to you how I answer the question
I just answer the question by telling
you my colleagues at the White House
Council has dealt with this and I would
refer you to them okay can you just
remind us what your colleague said from
the White House Council so we have it I
would I would refer you to them and they
will share their statement with you all
of you your statements from that Podium
you've stated that the president stands
by his comment from the 2020 campaign
that he never once discussed his son's
overseas business dealings with his son
and you stood at that Podium and you
reaffirmed that do you stand by your
reaction what I will say is nothing has
changed nothing has changed and I will
leave it there anything else I will
refer you to the White House Council
this is not a change I just answered the
question you asked you just asked me do
does my statement change I just told you
nothing has changed that's answering the
questions
yeah Stephen
I'm calling on your colleague right now
go ahead thank you to follow up on my
colleague is there anything that you can
say with regard to this text message and
what the president's son was
alleging was the president there or not
I would refer you to my colleagues at
the White House Council what a great job
what a great job you don't have to know
anything you literally don't have to
know anything
uh what do you have for lunch today well
I'll refer you to the other guy and what
are you doing
this woman is just dictionary it's just
the job right so you sort of don't even
you can't even fully blame her for being
horrible because in some ways she's
actually brilliant at it because she
could just stand up there doing nothing
over and over and over again so she's
doing exactly what they want her to do
but there the point is that there is a
scandal
uh there is a scandal that has happened
that finally seems to be breaking
through to a degree and by the way the
timing is perfect because it'll also
help them push Biden aside because they
know he's not up to running for
president and all that kind of stuff
[Music]